ah hello you're just in time for your
session
oh no i'm wearing a neutral unoffensive
top i have a camera and a mouth by the
unofficial rules of the internet echo
chamber that gives me authority to speak
on issues surrounding mental health hi
my name is grace hubbard if you do not
know now you know your life is different
now i am not a professional therapist or
a life coach but sometimes i play one on
the internet okay very exciting business
today this video is sponsored by
cerebral which is a fun word to say
because it sounds like you're burping in
your mouth while you're saying a very
uh high-fluent word love that love
getting the guts out through the mouth i
was very excited when cerebral wanted to
work with me on a video it gave me a
real opportunity to think about what i
want to say the internet is such an
important platform for
expressing ideas that can change the
world what would you do if you knew you
could not fail i'm working on some good
impressions of some really inspiring
leaders lately cerebral for those of you
that don't know is an online mental
health platform that provides access to
prescription medication management and
therapy for anxiety depression insomnia
and other conditions all for a flat
monthly rate treatment for adhd bipolar
and ptsd are also available in certain
states cerebral offers online
conveniency and privacy the two holy
grail items that the internet could
provide you with it allows you to do
visits with your provider your therapist
or your care counselor online from the
privacy of your own home you can message
your care team at any time it's like
having your care team in your pocket on
your mobile device and there's
comprehensive care your care team at
cerebral works together to create the
best treatment plan for you your
therapist your care counselor and your
prescriber are all talking together
which doesn't normally happen in
traditional settings it's affordable
with or without insurance you can start
cerebral without insurance however
cerebral is in network with certain
insurers you start by filling out an
online form it's a simple questionnaire
process super easy you answer a few
questions to help cerebral understand
what you're going through and from there
you can choose to subscribe to one of
three different membership options based
on your budget and your needs from there
the convenience continues they offer an
app that's available on google play or
in the app store champion your mental
health as cerebral's new year slogan and
that's cute if you're interested you can
click the link in my description to
start filling out your questionnaire and
get matched with your provider right
away and your first month starts at only
thirty dollars i'm getting excited on
your behalf oh all right what does this
have to do with what we're talking about
in the video today a lot we're talking
about mental health we're talking about
strategies and analogies that can help
you in your life caveat they might not
again there's not enough information or
conversation around all this right now
so happy to be adding to a very small
pile i've recently discovered a concept
that is floating around on the internet
most specifically tick tock yes
sometimes i go on tick-tock and it
scares me a little bit but it also
entices me like dairy there's a fun and
popular theory now being circulated
called crab mentality have you heard
about this crab mentality also known as
crab theory to make it extra
professional also known as the crab
bucket effect for those that prefer to
visualize a bucket when thinking about
their mental health sometimes i do the
idea behind it is that a single crab in
a bucket can get itself out with no
problem a bunch of crabs in a bucket
however will fight and keep each other
from getting out of the bucket so much
so that people that put crabs in buckets
apparently don't need to put a lid on it
when there's a lot of them in there
because they'll keep grabbing at each
other and pulling each other down rather
than working together because they're
crabs
and they got little brains thinking
behind it if i can't have it neither can
you in groups people will try to reduce
the self-confidence or the ability of
those around them in order to get what
they want so i guess the idea is to
recognize where you have crabs in your
life that are pulling you down and to
try to release or remove yourself from
the crabby situation i think it's a
pretty effective analogy it gives you
cate blanche to just look around at
those you're working with and say you're
a crab you're a crab you're a crab
you're a crab i'm gonna get the [ __ ] out
of this bucket you nasties it got me
thinking about how the animal world is
so ripe with analogies for us to use to
better ourselves in our relationships
creative endeavors personal lives in
general animals
don't have access to therapy as far as i
know and so their natural survival
instincts their innate capacity to
survive
is the purest form
of mental health
ish what other animal behaviors are out
there that can be used as rich metaphors
to enrich our personal lives and
well-being and oh i found a few the fun
thing about the internet is you really
don't need any credentials to put out
some really grandiose wide sweeping
ideas about uh mental health that
hopefully catch steam and become
truths so i'd like to introduce you some
other animal behavior analogies that i
think can be applied to your everyday
life in order to help you achieve
success in whatever form that means to
you this is science and poetry combined
and that essentially is what
psychology is let me get my list i've
written these down all the information
about these animal behaviors has been
plucked randomly from a variety of
unsourced uh websites so thank you so
much for not disputing any of the
absolutely
sound arguments that i will be
presenting to you today the opossum
postulate how do you pronounce opossum a
possum a possum a possum a possum okay
and that's how we find out answers to
questions opossums can play dead for up
to four hours to avoid death or capture
by a predator how does this apply to you
when predators start to threaten you i.e
depression anxiety or literally anything
that threatens to disturb what i call
don't touch me time what do you do play
dead i guess some professionals call it
taking a mental health day cancel
everything cancel on everyone give them
little to no information it's your
anxiety and you'll cry in your bed if
you want to also when possible play dead
sometimes they secrete a terrible odor
and foam at the mouth to give the full
effect to the predator that they're dead
when you decide to play dead or take a
mental health day commit get in bed
binge your reality show that you really
don't care much about but it distracts
you from all the cyclical negative
self-talk secrete those bad smells or
some buffalo cauliflower and let your
butthole rip all night foam at the mouth
commit to the full illusion take some
pictures of yourself crying post it on
social media so your boss predator knows
to back off you're ripping potential
sharks under a weighted blanket cause
it's me time it's the possum postulate
nature the ferret philosophy did you
know that female ferrets will die
if they don't mate once they go into
heat morbid and sexy how does this
relate to you obviously this is about
getting what you want when you've set
your sights on something you have to go
for it like you're gonna die if you
don't a sexy fair philosopher once said
get your [ __ ] ass up and work in
other words if you get horny for an idea
or a goal you have to that idea slash
goal like your life depends on it the
ferret philosophy the sloth drop sloths
are majestic and horrifying creatures to
me one of their most endearing qualities
to me is that they relieve themselves
once a week and when they do they can
poop up to one third of their body
weight they can shift a third of their
body in one go how does this apply to
you easy when it's time to let something
go you gotta let it go i'm talking toxic
friends unfulfilling relationship dead
end job what's another word for poop
when you identify a surplus of crap in
your life you don't want to get rid of
it little by little you want to have a
big bm to get to a bm big bowel movement
to get to a better me the sloth dropped
simple the giraffe hypothesis or the
giraffe hypocitis or the giraffe
hypothesis did you know that male
giraffes will test a female giraffe's
fertility by drinking her piss now you
know it nature is delicate and beautiful
how does this apply to you easy this
obviously connects to romantic
relationships pleasurable partnerships
finding the right partner can be a very
difficult and complex situation you're
really not going to know someone until
you experience the more intimate details
of that person psychologically
physically spiritually so in line with
the giraffe hypothesis you got to
metaphorically drink their pee
you have to experience the intimate
aspects of them to see if it's a right
fit otherwise you're in trouble drink
their piss to see if it's a myth drink
their pee see if it's meant to be i told
you science poetry that's psychology
you're still following along right i
hope you're taking notes tongue-eating
laos lessons there's a parasite called
zimathoa exigua
the female tongue-eating house is a
parasite that enters fish through the
gills it will attach itself to the
fish's tongue over time it will destroy
the fish's tongue attach itself to the
stump of what was the fish's tongue and
thus becomes the tongue how does this
apply to you uh
easy if you don't like the way that
someone is doing something perhaps you
think you can do it better you gotta get
in there eat their tongue become their
tongue now you're a tongue this one's a
bit savage there's probably a more
gentle metaphor about just sliding
yourself without disruption into a
position in which you benefit if that
doesn't work eat their tongue horned
lizard blood blizzards the horned lizard
has a very subtle way of evading
predators when the horned lizard is in a
precarious situation it squirts blood
from its eyes how does this apply to you
simple whenever you find yourself in a
stressful situation reach for the bag of
blood packets that you keep in your
purse go to the bathroom drip them below
your eyes and then tell whoever it is
that you need to leave and if they ask
you any questions that's [ __ ] up of
them get you and your bloody lizard eyes
out of there wow we have reached the end
of our session this was incredible for
me these are some theories that i have
been devoted to working on and i'm very
excited that i finally got to share them
with you today these animal metaphors
are rich they are profound they are
enlightening and they are the reason i
will probably not be allowed to visit
zoos anymore so i hope you were able to
find something interesting entertaining
and educational here thank you guys so
much for watching if you like this video
give it a thumbs up and if you're
interested in cerebral click the link in
the description below i'm gonna go drop
it like a sloth before i have an actual
terrible accident other than that i
don't know
another fun one that a lot of people
know the otter idea popular fact that
otters fall asleep holding hands with
their love so they don't float away from
each other in the night so cute how does
this apply to you always fall asleep
with your phone and a bat in your hand
when you wake up you're gonna need one
or the other so keep them next to you at
all times while you're sleeping